[Müzik]
Merhaba
soru soracağım mücadele kelimesi sizler
için ne ifade ediyor Bunu biraz düşünün
sonunda tekrardan bu soruyla ilgili bir
sorun daha olacak
iyileşti
en son turda Galatasaray'ın koptu Ondan
sonra Bilmiyorum zaten alacağımı sürpriz
oldu bana
asıl burcu bu arkamda gördüğünüz küçük
kız ben sizin Daha önce tanışmadığınız
bu küçük kızın hikayesini anlatıyor
olacağım babamın ilgisi sayesinde
otomobil sporlarıyla tanıştım Karting
yapmaya başladım Tam da bu yaşta ve
Aslında Onun öncesinde bir astım
hastalığım vardı sürekli oyunu yarım
bırakmak zorunda kalan arkasında havlusu
olan annesi Aman kızım konuşma Aman
kızım koşma terleme konuşursan
terliyorsun ama sürekli böyle bir annem
vardı ama babam Anneme çok benzemiyordu
otomobil sporlarına olan ilgisi
sayesinde bir gün televizyonda gördüğüm
amatörlere yönelik bir Karting yarışı
için tuzla Cardin pistine gitti ve
yarışmaya başladı Ben de her hafta sonu
Babamla beraber onunla Eee piste
gidiyordum
antrenmanlar yapıyordum sonra bir gün
dedi ki Burcu yarışmak ister misin Ben
de olur dedim Yani bunun çok böyle beni
Zorlayacak bir şey olduğunu bilmeden
açıkçası
yarışmaya başlayınca bir anda Tabii
yarış profesyonel bir şeye dönüştü babam
öyle her hafta sonu beni götürüp yağmur
çamur kar demeden beni çalıştırıyor
rakiplerim erkek onları geçmemi istiyor
tabii onun da bir hırsı var kendimi
aşmam gereken kabuğumu kırmam gereken
bir dönem Şimdi dönüp baktığımda o günkü
Burcu'yu hatırladığımda şunu
hissediyorum çok sancılı bir dönemde ama
büyük değişimlerde o sancılar içinde
oluyor yani bir yerde bir sızı
hissettiğinizde bir sancı
hissettiğinizde emin olun ki çok büyük
bir değişim var arkasında ve bence bu
çok pozitif oluyor insanın kendini
aştığı geliştirdiği kabuğunu kırdığı
zamanlar oluyor ve benim için de öyle
bir dönem oldu Gün geçtikçe hızlandım
rakiplerimi geçer oldum
Tabii ki babam her zaman Benim
yanımdaydı şimdi Tabii ki babası kızını
yarıştırıyor gibi bir algıya kapılmayın
yarıştırırken Çok da fazla fedakarlık
veriyorduk Çünkü
çoğu zaman arkadaşlarımın
antrenmanlarından kalan lastikleri Ben
yarışırken takıyordum ya da
arkadaşlarımın yedek motorlarıyla
yarışıyordum Yani çok da aslında
otomobil sporları Tabii ki Birazcık
popüler görünse de aslında birazcık da
Maddi güce de dayalı bir spor olduğu
için o zaman bazı fedakarlıklarda
bulunmam gerekiyordu Bana en çok sorulan
sorulardan biri kaza yaptın mı öyle bir
kaza yaptım ki kartingle
Bursa Nilüfer pistindeydik
rakibimle aynı anda viraja girdik ben
tabii gördüğünüz gibi minyon kızım o
zaman da daha da milyonun ben çok hafif
olduğum için lastikle çarpışınca iki
lastik Ben bir anda şunu hatırlıyorum
havaya fırladım 4 defa döndüm sonra yere
düştüm ama sağ bacağım gokarttın içinde
kalmıştı bu kartta benim üstüme düştü
gözlerimi açtığımda böyle bir güruh bana
bakıyordu ama kimse yanıma gelemiyordu
Çünkü ben hareketsiz bir şekilde
durduğum için ya bayıldım ya da öldüğümü
düşündüler babam ortalıkta yok Asla
görmüyorum
sonra bir
arkadaşımın babası geldi beni hastaneye
kaldırdılar şans eseri Ne kırık var ne
çıkık var Hiçbir şey yok ve piste geri
döndük babam bana hiç soru sormuyor
Çünkü bembeyaz olmuş kireç gibi suratı
Hiçbir şey sormadı Sadece dedi ki yani
bundan sonra Sen ne yapmak istiyorsan
ben dedim ki ben yarışmaya devam etmek
istiyorum
piste geri döndüm antrenmanlarımı yaptım
ve nasıl oldu bilmiyorum ama o gün o
Pistin en hızlı turunu imza attım ve o
gün şunu biliyordum artık bu sporu
sadece ben istediğim için yapacaktım
Yani bir gün babam benim maddi olarak
bir yerlerde bırakırsa da
benim üzerime düşen çok büyük bir görev
vardı
Tabii ki bu noktada Ben bir şekilde
görünür de olmam lazım ama
utanarak bunu yapıyorum Aslında bir anda
bir gün dergi karıştırırken bir
arkadaşımın röportajına denk geldim
Ondan sonra okudum röportajı dedim bir
dakika kağıdı kalemi elime alayım Aynı
soruları kendime sorayım cevaplayayım
Dergiye göndereyim verge bildiğiniz
eleme Kağıt kaleme aldığım yazdım
mektupla Dergiye gönderdim Hiç de umudum
yok açıkçası yani böyle şey mi olur İki
gün sonra beni aradılar Merhaba Burcu
Biz senin röportajını çok beğendik
Sadece fotoğraf çekimi yapmak istiyoruz
Tuzla kartın peşinde buluşabilir miyiz
ben şoktayım Nasıl ya hani gerçekten
böyle röportajım Nasıl beğendiniz Aynı
soruları sordum ben nasıl oldu Sonra
gördüğünüz gibi o fotoğrafı çektiler
bana Demek ki gittiğim yol doğruydu
Tabii ben buradan aldığım gazla beraber
televizyonlara işte markaların
ceo'larına ya da nerede ne görürsem
Merhaba ben Burcu yarışmak istiyorum
diye herkese mail atıyordum ya da mektup
gönderiyordum o zamanın teknolojisi
Neyse yani 9 2000'li yıllardan
bahsediyoruz ve sonra Tabi ben şimdi ben
Büyüyorum ama Hayallerim de benimle
beraber büyüyor
babamın Maddi gücü yeterli olmayacak
bunu da biliyorum ama ben bir gün
otomobille yarışma istiyorum Yani asıl
hayalim o ve pistte olmayı istiyorum O
zaman da bir marka Bir kupa yapıyor ve
yerinde 25 bin kişi izliyor Yani öyle
bir şampiyonu ve aynı zamanda o dönemin
işte ünlü isimleri yani oyuncuları
sanatçıları vesaire bu kupayı
yarışıyorlar ve ben orada olmaya o kadar
hayal ediyorum ki Ama hayal etme
noktasında şöyle bir şey var ben denedim
oluyor bu gerçek
otomobile gerçekten biniyorum
direksiyonunu tutuyorum gözlerimi
kapatıyorum o pisti dolaşıyorum hayal
etmek böyle bir şey bence bir gün yine
telefonum çaldı polo'yu diye kapta
yarışan arkadaşın Melis dedi ayağını
kırdığı için yerine sen yarışır mısın
Ben çok nasıl Gerçekten mi Tabii ki
yarışın
Babama söyledim babam Biliyor tabii
benim burada ne kadar çok yarışmak
istediğimi sadece şunu söyle Burcu sen
araba kullanmayı bilmiyorsun ki dedi yok
biliyorum dedim Neyse biz piste geldik
şöyle bir an vardı otomobilin üzerine
Burcu yazısını görüyorsunuz ya benim
gördüğüm o ilk an kalbim öyle çarpıyor
ki yani
hayalimle karşı karşıyayım Adım yazıyor
Otomobilde ve bu muhteşem bir şey
hayalim hayalini kurduğum o otomobil
karşımda duruyor Arabaya bindim Vitesi
taktım ama araba yürümüyor
arabası stop etti Tabii sonra ikinci
dönem üçüncü deneme derken ben bir
şekilde arabayı böyle böyle böyle
götürdü pislik çıktı bu arada ezbere
biliyorum
en büyük Şansıma ama pistte birinci
vites var ikinci vites var üçüncü vites
var gerisi yok
Asla dörde de atamıyorum korkudan ikiye
de çekemiyorum böyle pır pır pırıl
dolaştım sonra dediler ki kalkış
yapacağız starta hazır olman lazım
start'ta araba yanıyordu
dediler ki Burcucuğum Sen istersen bu
yarışa girme ya o an
Hissettiğim şey sanki beni birisi bir
uçurumdan aşağıya attı çok büyük bir
ders oldu bana çünkü ne olursa olsun ne
kadar isterseniz isteyin Evet istemek
başarmanın yarısı ama onu da çok iyi
hazırlanmak da gerekiyor
dersimi çok iyi aldım Sonra döndük bana
dediler ki Tabii hevesini de kırmak
istemiyorlar Bir sonraki yarışa biz seni
dahil edeceğiz hemen döndüm İstanbul'a
sürekli antrenman yapıyorum Sürekli ama
bir şekilde oldu Çok güzel otomobil
kullanıyor ve ben bir sonraki yarışa
girdim O bir sonraki yarışta 16 yaşında
pistlerde yarışan en genç pilot oldum ve
bu benim için çok güzel bir başlangıçtı
şurada şunu anladım
başlamadığın hiçbir şeyin kazananı ya da
kaybedeni olamazsın O gün o bir yerden
düşme hissi Aslında kaybetmek gibiydi
ama çok büyük bir başlangıcında
dönüm noktasıydı Çünkü kendimle alakalı
bir eksiği fark etmiştim ve aynı zamanda
büyük bir ders çıkartmıştım ve de
aslında bir yandan da benim otomobille
yarış serüvenimin bir başlangıcı olmuştu
Tabii babam orada benim bu hayal
kırıklığımdan ötürü bir yandan kendi
yarışma isteği yani sonuçta yarış
kariyerinde oldu bir ölçüde kenara
bırakmıştı
bir yandan O da yarışmak istiyor ama
benim de önüme geçmek istemiyor Benim de
yolumu açmak istiyor o dönem böyle bir
arayış içine girdi şans eseri bir tane
yarış otomobili satın aldı ya yarışa
doğru dedim öyle bakmayın Yani gerçekten
her şey yarım yamalak otomobile ama var
yani o otomobil otomobile benziyor En
azından
Babam dedi ki Burcu Yani kendi yarışmak
istiyor ya onu da söyleyemiyor bana
seninle bir ralli yarışına girelim mi
dedi Ben de RAL yarışı yani çok farklı
bir disiplin otomobil sporları çok büyük
bir çatı ama ralli bunun bir branşı
sadece ve disiplini gerçekten çok farklı
baba dedim yani toprakta giden araba mı
olur ya ben pisçiyim Yapma etme Bir de
sağ koltuğuna oturtuyorsun beni falan
hani Olur mu öyle şey falan dedim Babam
dedi ki Bence bu kadar ön yargılı olma
gel biz bir yarışa girelim Bu arada 3
yarışlık bir şampiyona
Tamam dedim girdik Belgrad ormanında 3
tane yarış yapacağız
ikisini de uçtuk
Yani tabii ki birisine yan yattık bir
tanesi de çamura battık bir tane yarış
bitirdik ama ben bugün
ralli branş ile tanıştım bir kere kayan
bir otomobil var
Doğa var bilinmezlik var sırada hayatımı
hep böyle Zorlu olmuş mücadele içinde
olmuş Her şeyimi tırnaklarımla kazıyorum
falan
yani doğanın mücadelesi hayvanlar
çıkıyor daha da zorlaştırdım ben işi
dedim ki baba ben ralli yapmak istiyorum
Sonra babam dedi ki
Yani artık sponsor bulursam bulduğum
kadar girersin dedi
ama otomobil hazır değil Bir şey değil
ya piste göre hazırlanmış bir otomobil
raliyle alakası yok Bu otomobil bir
hazırlanması lazım falan ben otomobili
boya sökücülerle söktüğüm zımparasını
Yaptın ondan sonra boyasını attık
Babamla beraber falan filan ama para yok
yani bir para lazım bu işe girmek için
Çünkü kayıt parası lastik parası benzin
parası falan Tabii ben yani Para bulmam
lazım şimdi herkese söylüyorum Merhaba
ben Burcu bana 10 TL sponsor olursanız
ben yarışa gireceğim diyorum herkes
bakıyor önce ciddi almıyor beni ya
gerçekten yarışa gireceğim şöyle bir kız
yani yarışacağım ben ya hayır araba
kullanıyorum Ben yarışa gireceğim
Bu arada 19 yaşındayım işte falan deyip
böyle 10 TL değer 2008 yılı Aslında
güzel para fena değil 10 TL çıkarıp
veren var Ay bu bizi acaba Hani
kandırıyor mu diyen var ama bir şekilde
işte 10 lira da veriyorlar falan ben
güzel bir bütçe yakaladım
otomobilin üzerinde Bazı fotoğraflar ve
isimler görüyorsunuz Onlar benim
sponsorlarım ilk yarışa girdim araba
Kayıp Aranıyor arabası gibi bir araba
ortalıkta dolaşıyor Allah Allah Gelen
geçen bana Pardon canım sen bir yakınını
mı arıyorsun diyor arkadaş bu kadar
yakın kaybolabilir mi Nasıl Kaybolsun
Hayır onlar benim sponsorlarım diyerek
böyle sponsorlar da bir gönderme
yapıyorum hala yapıyorum anlamışsınızdır
ilk yarışımı böyle yaptım ama yarışa
girmek fiyasko Çünkü niye ben yarışa
gireceğim dedikçe ya Burcu Saçmalama ya
o kadar Toprak yarış bilmem ne uzun daha
kısasına gir yemin ediyorum 33 yaşına
geldim hala bir konuyu anlattığımda
herkes şu cümleyi kurmadı ya Sen en
iyisini yaparsın böyle bir cümle
kurulacak bir noktayı Bir Gün Hayatta
Hayal ediyorsanız Böyle bir şey asla
olmayacak çünkü insanlar iyi bir şey
söylediklerini zannederek en kötüsünden
başlıyorlar söylemeye ve bu Eğer bu
insanlara kalırsa bu hayatta kimse
Hiçbir şey yapamaz ben zaten yarışa
girmeye niyetlenmişim 10 TL 10 TL
insanlardan Para topluyorum yani Bırakın
da ben girip Girmeyeceğim ama artık
karar vereyim hiçbir zaman duymadım Hala
da duymuyorum çok az insandan duyuyorum
Sen bu işi yaparsın diyen o yüzden
onlara hiç aldırmayın Ben ralliyi
Hayatın ta kendisi olarak belirliyorum
neden
niye sevdim aslında ralli'de
bilinmezlikler var Mesela benim Biliyor
musunuz Bir şampiyonluğum sadece kaputu
açmam yüzünden gitti ya da bir yarışta
bir lastiğin patladığı için
birinciliği Kaybettim ya da bir yerden
kaza yaptım tamam Allah kahretsin Burada
Bitti dediğim anda dağın arkasından
gelen 3-4 kişi otomobili çevirip
tekrardan bizi yarışa gönderdi Yani
bitişlerin başlangıçların bir orta
noktası orası bazen böyle hayat size
küsmüş gibi hissettirip Sonradan bir
anda insanlar çıkınca otomobil çalışınca
mucize yaratıyor Hayat da böyle bazen
Mucizeler oluyor hayatlarımızda ama
bitişlerimiz ve sonlarımız da oluyor o
yüzden ralli benim hayatta nefes alma
şeklim ve beni hayata çok iyi hazırlıyor
Çünkü her an her şeye hazırlıklıyım
bence
hayatı böyle baktığınızda her an her şey
olacakmış gibi hazırlıklı
davrandığınızda çok güçlü
hissediyorsunuz kendinizi güçlü olmak
başka bir şey ama güçlü hissetmek daha
kıymetli bir şey o yüzden güçlü
hissettiğiniz anı kovalayın Bence bir
gün herhalde kariyerimin ikinci yarışı
etap'tan çıktı şimdi bizim etaplarımız
biliyorsunuz Toprak etaplar zaman zaman
asfalt etaplar ama etaplar yani
yarıştığımız yerler bittikten sonra
Aslında yarış tamamen bitmiş olmuyor Biz
etabın sonuna geliyoruz yanındaki
kopilotun zamanların tutulduğu bir karne
var Onu hakeme veriyor hakeme verdikten
sonra da aslında etabı bitirmiş oluyoruz
tam o noktadayız
bir vitese taktım yok
çıktıktan sonra hemen Maslak'a
gelirsiniz İstanbul'da bilenler
geldik ama herkes yarış arabası
görmekten gaza gelmiş ve bir tane
minibüs askeriyeye doğru uçmuş trafik
böyle Eyvah dedim çıkar çıkmaz durduk
birinci vites yok ikinci vites yok artık
3 de yok ama ne var 4
Şimdi banyoya araba kullananlar
bilecekler 4 viteste otomobili hareket
ettirmek gerçekten oldukça zor zor tabii
Bizim arabada yanıyordu neredeyse
Dumanlar Çıka çıka herkes bize bakıyor
ikinci kazağı olmak üzere neredeyse biz
arabayı hareket ettirdik ve biz korna
elimde ve gazla gazla'ya gidiyoruz Şu an
star binasında olduğu yerde bir AVM
otoparkında servis alanımız var şimdi
biz öyle heyecanlı gelmişiz ki bir tane
güvenlik görevlisi var böyle başında
bekliyor Kapının pislik görünce
telaşlandı açık kapıyı kapattı adam
bariyeri
ya Hayatımda bu kadar yani çok Yaşadığım
bir an olamaz çünkü yani oraya kadar
gelmişim zorla Peki elimizde ne var geri
vites
[Kahkaha]
arabayı geri vitese taktık Ondan sonra
geri geri geri geri yarışı bitirdik ve
birincilik Kupamızı kaldırdık
ve o gün bugündür Diyorum ki bu hayat
%50 daha fazlası yok yani şu an
buradayız ralin'in böyle bir güzelliği
de var O anı çok güzel hissediyorsun
hayattan izole oluyorsun yarışırken
Hayat
150 zaman bilemezsin ve tecrübe
dinlemeyi de çok fazla sevmem açıkçası
çünkü ben onu yaptığımda ne hissediyorum
ve onunla ilgili Evet Bir fikrim olmalı
ama onu asıl o başıma geldiğinde nasıl
bir tepki veriyorum benim için kıymetli
ama bence artık ya kazanıyorsun ya
kaybediyorsun Bence püf noktası şu
Sonuna kadar mücadele etmek yani
kanımızın son damlası vardır ya onun
Sonuna kadar mücadele etmek gibi
vicdanımız rahat olsun Ben yani o gün
orada geri viteslere giremeseydim Eğer
içeriye Ya ben Sonuna kadar mücadele
ettim gururuyla da çıkacaktım Bence o
benim için de birincilikti o yüzden çok
güzel bir hala anlatırken duygulandım
bir anım
2010 yılı benim hayatımın bir diğer
dönüm noktası Çünkü ilk defa bir
sponsorum oldu bir Alman şirketi bana
sponsor olmak istedi ve arkadaşlar
parayı bulunca insanlara ilk ne yapar
arabasını değiştirir Ben de arabamı
değiştirdim ve yeni bir otomobille
yarışmaya başladı daha hızlı otomobil
yarış yapan bir otomobile benziyor En
azından ve dedim ki Ben bununla
yarışacağım
çok daha işte rakiplerim de o zaman
değişiyor daha çok erkeklerle
yarışıyorum falan ve biz o sene bu yeni
otomobille en geç kadın şampiyon yani
kadın
şampiyonu olduk ve hala Bugün 21 yaşında
kazandım bu şampiyonluk ünvanı beni hala
en genç kadın raylı şampiyonu yapıyor Ve
tabii ki benim en çok övündüğüm
erkekleri geçerek de bir şampiyonluğumuz
var o yıl Ve tabii ki yeni sponsor yeni
araba ve şampiyonluklar Ben o kadar
mutlu başladım ki serüvene 2015
senesinde ralli otomobilimi satın aldım
o sene kadınlar ikincisi olduk Sonra
gençler üçüncüsü olduk Türkiye
şampiyonasında yarıştım Yani bütün
yarışları kovaladım ilk sezonunda benim
sonra 2012 yılında devam ettik Eee ve
çok güzel bir şekilde erkekleri de
geçerek
sınıfımızda tek kadın olarak sınıf
birinciliğini de kazandı
2013-2014 derken Benim tabi hayallerim
büy ümeye devam ediyor
dedim ki ben bu arabayı satayım ve
yerine yenisini alayım
Sattım ama bazı stratejik Hatalar yaptım
çünkü yerine yenisini koyamadım
Tamam sorun yok dedim Orada da şunu
öğrendim şimdi bize adımlarımızı ileri
Atmaya çalışıyoruz ama bazen daha güzel
şeyler için bu adımımızı geri atmaktan
alıkoyuyoruz kendimizi Çünkü bunu
yenilgi zannediyoruz oysaki o bir adım
yere atmak büyük resmi görmek ve ne
yapacağına bir kez daha bakmak Demek
bana göre yani şöyle düşünün bir engel
var önünüzde onu atlamak istiyorsunuz
şöyle atlar mısınız Hayır ilk
yapacağınız hareket şuradan bir güç alıp
onu o şekilde atlamak vardır bu bence
Hayatta en önemli adımlardan biri geriye
attığımız adım Çünkü o zaman egoları
susturuyorsunuz içinizdeki kötü sesi
susturuyorsunuz büyük resmi görüyorsunuz
ve ben de öyle yaptım çok da işime
yaradı Tabii ki hayatta
Ben hep mücadele ettiğimi düşündüm çünkü
orada otomobili satmamla alakalı bir şey
de şu Aslında en çok kullandığım şey
mücadele mücadele hep mücadele ediyorum
ya bir şeyler de bana gelsin Yani hep
böyle hep böyle bir mücadele ile ilgili
bir
barışamadığın bir durum vardı Ve ben
bunu fark ettiğimde Niye ben bu kadar
mücadeleye takmışım ki oldum Aslında
hepimizin hayatlarında bazı mücadeleleri
var Yani iş için İş için Neyse yani fark
etmez sebebinin ne olduğu ama bunları
anlatırken Biz kendi hikayelerimizi bazı
kalıpların üzerine çok dururuz onlardan
çok bahsederiz altını çok çizeriz
Ben de mücadelenin Altına çok çiziyordum
Siz bir bakın mesela hayatınızda hangi
kelimelerin hangi kavramların altını
çiziyorsunuz ve Aslında sorun burada o
çizdiğimiz altını çizdiğimiz kavramlarla
ilgili bir sıkıntımız var hayatta ve ben
mücadele kelimesiyle barıştım
barıştıktan sonra da harika şeyler oldu
Hayalini bile kuramadığım kurum yani
Aklıma gelmeyen şeyler oldu zorlukların
üstesinden gelmek istiyorsak gerçekten
onları önce kabul etmekten başlamalıyız
Bence kabul ettiğinizde çünkü onun ne
olduğunu daha net görüyorsunuz
çözümlerinizi de ona göre Aslında
bulmaya başlıyorsunuz yani yolun
önündeki o pürüzleri açmak demek Bence
bu
Ben de böyle yaptım Ve tabii ki
sonrasında Herkesin beni tanıdığı
bir viral video ile bir Tabii ki
yıllardır yarışıp daha az kişinin beni
tanıdığı Hatta çoğunlukla erkeklerin
tanıdığı ve benden ben bundan hep
muzdariptim neden hep erkekler deyip
böyle sinirlendiğim bir noktada Aslında
kadınların da ya Burcu Hanım yani Ben
sizin sayenizde Ehliyet sınavına girdim
ben sizin sayenizde trafiğe Yeniden
çıktım dedikleri bir noktada bir anda
böyle başka bir şey oldu ve artık
Kadınlar da Belki benden feyz alıyorlar
Belki beni örnek gösteriyorlar çünkü
erkekler bu noktada bazen kadınlara bir
dakika ya sen otur sağda ben Kullanırım
Hani kadın arabayı kullanmasını bilse
dahi sen yorulma hayatım Öyle bir şey
değil yani yorulma falan değil o Sen
otur orada Sağ koltuk senin falan deyip
böyle durum öyle bir noktaya geldiği
için haliyle ben bu kadınların sesini
duymaya başladım Aa böyle bir şey varmış
diye çünkü ben hayatımda hep otomobil
kullanıyordum bilmiyordum böyle bir şey
olduğunu Ve beni bu bambaşka bir
pencereyle tanıştırdı Bu benim için çok
mutluluk verici bir şey Eğer bazı
insanlara buradan feyz almalarını
sağlayabilmişsem ne güzel Biz Kadınlar
Zaten her şeyi başarırız otomobilin de
en iyi şekilde kullanırız Eğer bunu
gösterebildiysem Ne mutlu ve tabii ki
sonrasında hayatında başka güzel işler
de olmaya başladı niye oldu çünkü ben
artık mücadele kelimesiyle barışık bir
insanım barıştığım için her şey çok daha
farklı ve çok daha farklı bir pencereden
bakıyorum dilerim Siz de bu
hayatınızdaki önemli kavramların ne
olduğunu farkına varırsınız Şimdi
soruyorum size mücadele kelimesi sizin
için ne ifade ediyor
Çok teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]